[Music]
my name is dr. Gary Clayman I'm the
founder and director of the Clayman
Theory Cancer Center at Tampa General
Hospital in Tampa Florida
we came to nucleus medical to create
animation for an app that we are
creating for the evaluation and risk
assessment of thyroid nodules for lumps
within the thyroid gland so this is
totally customized to the patient so the
patient puts in all of their information
then the the app amalgamates all that
and creates a three-dimensional
visualization of their thyroid and their
mass within it they can they can put
information in for example if they've
had a period of time of observation they
can watch their mess grow get a sense of
what it looks like they can also turn it
around they can see where it's located
in the body it's absolutely amazing our
desire for our app was develop something
that was three-dimensional for patients
so they really get a concept of what
their thyroid looks like and what their
lump or nodule within their thyroid
looks at nucleus developed the
three-dimensional animation for the
application
it totally integrates into the
application if I told you you had a two
sonometer mass in your thyroid gland you
would say to some
this is the spigen I'm not really very
concerned about but when you see it
within your thyroid level you see how it
deforms if I regret and what it looks
like on the front surface and the back
surface which is really what the
animation offers the patient it really
gives him a much better concept of the
pea
I've enjoyed all of my interactions with
the Faceman
they've been insightful they've been
very timely in their efforts when we you
know obviously there's iterations and
development of these animations and
every time that we came back to them
they were receptive to our reviews and
really sort of intellectualize those
comments and then put them into action
into making this even better than we